[Musica]
caiazzo
saia
no non voglio avevate promesso che mi
avreste lasciato stare
gli onesti del tuo video non può
succedere adesso non posso
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] salve youtubers barone era
dalla vita che non lo dicevo e benvenuti
in questa piccolissima serie estiva
chiamata confessioni eh sì perché alla
fine vacanza per tutti ma non pensiate
che non stia già lavorando
mentalmente almeno ai video da settembre
in poi
steiner semplicemente ad agosto non ho
mai avuto un cazzo voglia di fare niente
perché invece gli altri giorni e io ma
non è quello il punto il punto è che
volevo portarvi qualcosa ad agosto ma
cosa se non i video principali quindi mi
è venuto in mente che non sputtanarci
molto più del normale e parlare di cose
che non ci sono piaciute anche magari
piacciono invece alla maggior parte
della popolazione mondiale e se dovessi
dire qualcosa di stupido qualcosa di
sbagliato su questa cosa qui mi
lincerebbero da qui all'eternità
quindi oggi parliamo di bienne dove di
game of thrones perché una domanda su
due che mi fate e hai visto game of
thrones dalla seconda in classifica
sarebbero hai visto che è uscito shark
nardò due sì l'ho visto l'ho visto l'ho
visto potete finalmente smettere di
rompermi corners con quella domanda lì e
quindi dio topic ti piace game of
thrones no
boni che già vedo commenti incredibili
sotto questo video fatevi mettere le
mani avanti prima che mele tagliate
tutto quello che dico sono opinioni
personali ma veramente tanto personali
non è il classico o posso dire il cazzo
che voglio perché tanto sono mie
opinioni come quelli che fanno dei
discorsi del cazzo che potrebbero essere
di nessun team il cielo e verde è no
marco il cielo non è verde
il cielo è azzurro no il cielo e verde
ed è una mia opinione e no brutta testa
di cazzo non è un'opinione quella è una
cagata
quindi questo per dire che è probabile
che pieno delle cagate ed è probabile
che dire delle cose che sono opinioni
personali
spero che siate abbastanza furbi da
capire la differenza tra le due
ma sono da sette anni su youtube quindi
ho pochissime speranze e quindi iniziamo
di game of thrones ne ho sentito sempre
parlare manco fosse debola quindi un
giorno di qualche mese fa si parla
dell'anno scorso ho deciso va beh
guardiamo la prima puntata sapendo già
che molto probabilmente non mi sarebbe
piaciuto il genere ma lì non ci posso
fare niente un genere che non mi piace
particolarmente
quindi guardo la prima bordata arriva
alla fine con una fatica disumana ho
detto no non mi piace ma annoiato fino
alla morte arrivederci e questo già lo
dissi tempo fa con errore perché poi la
gente non ha più lasciato stare
ma continuano non può giudicarlo dalla
prima puntata nonostante non abbia
giudicato dalla prima puntata non può
giudicarlo dalla prima puntata devi
continuare ad andare avanti
devo finire di guardare due big del
fiume tiorba scuse scuse e dunque ho
deciso di riprenderla qualche settimane
fa neanche un paio di mesi fa e l'ho
ripresa sono arrivato ben fino alla
settima puntata della prima stagione e
poi basta
sono bravo è stato migliorato un sacco
adesso cercherò di spiegarvi perché non
mia non mi è piaciuto particolarmente
mai sbagliato dire che non mi è piaciuto
e che proprio non ci sono alcune cose
che non le ho capite diciamo così così e
mimì paracula dunque come partire mia
anno
quello non lo posso negare mi ha
annoiato queste sette puntate sono state
incredibilmente pesanti e lente e ma
sono puntate per presentare i personaggi
assolutamente vero anche se c'è da dire
che non è che siano così tanti i
personaggi almeno nelle prime puntate
non sono così tanti personaggi da
presentare e mi sembra che ci siano
andando molto molto molto lentamente per
presentarli è il mio più grande problema
con questa cosa qua e non che se la
siano presa con calma che anzi un pregio
quella cosa lì ma che in sette puntate
ancora non si capisca bene dove la gente
voglia andare a parare e le puntate
della prima stagione sono dieci e durano
anche più di un'ora a botta
no ma è molto probabile che non capisca
il senso però è noioso e io ho visto
serie molto noioso e tra su carta che
erano in noiose ma in realtà adesso
piaciuto da morire tra cui the wire per
esempio se tu guardi il retro della
custodia dei dvd di the wire addormenti
a metà però in poi se lo guardi e
sviluppato talmente tanto bene che è
impossibile staccarsi non sto
paragonando un semi polizia squadre
mostra nostra l'amor di dio ma è solo
per esempio propriamente quindi è in
stecchette puntate di demo trotz non è
successo nulla che portasse avanti
realmente la trama immaginatevi questa
cosa che vi sto dicendo da un fan di che
mostrano come me non far nel senso che
l'odio non vanno nel senso che non
sapeva cosa aspettarsi arrivare lì e
dopo sette puntate da un'ora quindi
sette ore di divisione e non è ancora
successo quasi nulla e poi perché poi la
gente dice come non è successo nulla è
successo questo questo questo questo
questo ma tutto questo questo questo
questo non ha portato avanti di mezzo
miglio
la trama mezzo sbatterò il gomito tante
di quelle volte che non vi immaginate
questo secondo me almeno data da esterno
ho visto queste siete puntate e non è
successo nulla e già mi immagino
morsicare i braccioli delle vostre sedie
perché sto dicendo una cazzata ma da
come lo assorbita io per me non è
successo quasi nulla i personaggi i
personaggi barra attori sono tutti
ottimi nel senso che hanno azzeccato
l'attore per il personaggio la faccia
dell'attore è azzeccata cento per cento
per la personalità del personaggio e
sono tutti bravissimi a parte quello là
del biondo che sembra il principe
azzurro di shrek
lui è quello che mi ha convinto merola
convinto meno nel senso che è bravo ma
forse gli altri sono anche più molto più
gravi come tyson gijon
lui è bravo hai visto che bello quando
un [ __ ] parla cerca di giudicare una
cosa che non ha neanche finito di
vederla prima stagione è bellissimo
internet ma il colpo di grazia per chi
già stava la mia attenzione stava
calando parecchio ma il popper colpo di
grazia è stato spoilers ovviamente per
chi non ha visto la serie la morte di re
robe tralasciando il fatto che ogni
volta che appariva re robert mi veniva
voglia di pizzica anni le guance perché
proprio il pacioccone mi ricordavo ogni
volta che primo un po bacco perché era
parecchio ubriaco e le guance con le
gote rosse proprio bacco semmai poi era
grasso a proposito internet
potresti finirla di prendere le cose
decenti che potrebbero essere divertenti
e rovinarle completamente farmele odiare
vi faccio un esempio proprio a caso e ho
già lo sai che ho iniziato a vedere game
of thrones per ora vista del mostro
genovino vero per favore no no vai a
morire in mezzo alla strada da tra le
atroce agonia di un verme intestinale e
bon perché io sto guardando se non puoi
se poi c'è non è un problema se esce
fuori una
il meme da che non sono un grande fan
dei meme proprio perché ti distruggono
quello che poco prima ti piaceva due
secondi telo disintegrano ma perché una
rottura di [ __ ] è come se tu avessi
un campanello si fa un suono buffo ma
come si dice in camera lo fa ogni volta
che modo premi e la gente l'idea molto
divertente e questa cosa funziona quando
suona li postino e quando suona al
qualcuno deve salire e basta ma se uno
per il divertimento inizia a suonarlo
ogni 3 4 secondi per tutta la tua vita e
che non diventa più un divertimento
diventa omicidio di secondo grado ed è
quello che un po succede con i tell e
quindi diamoci una calmata internet per
favore la morte di re napoli sapevo che
sarebbe morto qualcuno prima o poi
perché se non volete spoiler di game of
thrones dovreste credo vivere in alaska
senza internet senza wifi a mangiare i
pesci presi con le mani nude perché
altrimenti dove fai un passo dove fai un
altro passo se hai di tre amicizie su
facebook la tua vita di game of thrones
è rovinata per sempre detto questo una
cosa che credo di aver capito in modo
sbagliato e chi è il protagonista in
quelle sette puntate
la risposta è più o meno tutti secondo
me per favore aspettate a scrivere nome
gano secondo me e da come l'ho vista io
do lore recepita in queste prime sette
puntate
non dico che se vi fosse solo uno di
protagonista ma dico che la storia era
ad imbuto nel senso che parte larga e
non ha idea di dove finisce
ma piano piano si incanala verso una
persona che era appunto re neutro
roberts come sono sempre in questi
giorni perché le società che sento già
gente tipo posto di frankestein con i
forconi e le torce infuocate sotto asp e
tutti hanno una loro storia che ha un
inizio ma in quel frangente lì non si
sapeva neanche quale sarebbe stata alla
fine l'unica storia
grande di game of thrones in quel
momento lì erano i figli legittimi direi
rom per c'era questa storia qui del
chissà cosa succede perché quello era
sparito perché quello era morto e di
linda gilli mi stava piacendo perché ho
detto chissà cosa si scoprirà in questo
mondo fantasy chissà qualche universo
parallelo mag qualsiasi cosa no era la
storia dei figli illegittimi e giani uno
dei due testicoli mei è arrotolato un po
più in là del divano ed è andato a
insinuarsi sotto il mobile del
televisore perché non me ne frega un
cazzo proprio sinceramente di sapere che
la storia era dei figli legittimi euro
per sé non me ne fregava niente so io
non ci possiamo fare nulla
pronta cosa era che appunto essendo
quella la trama più logica di chi e
mostrano 5 il momento lì lo so che ci
sarà di tutto dopo cambia da così a così
che ne so ma in quel momento nella trama
erano i figli legittimi dire robert
boyle roberts uomo robert muore
sì ma come è successo una roba ad uno
dei personaggi importanti di che
mostruosi in queste sette puntate che è
successo è morto o no all dicendolo è
morto ce ne hanno parlato non si è
neanche visto mi hanno rotto le scatole
con robert dei suoi figli legittimi
biondi che poi basta tiragli sui
pantaloni per vedere subito mi naturali
o no e e poi muore con una guardia che
lo dice ma la chicca che ha trasformato
la serie drammatica fantasia na sit com
per me è stata come è morto e cosa è
successo
l'ha investito un cinghiale o no
probabilmente nel libro
leggendola il meno ridicola che sentirla
e il personaggio da cui è partita tutta
l'indagine principale in quel momento lì
di game of thrones ed è
un morto fuori campo ma è che è il
sangue sono gli eau topi non ho capito
un cazzo di abbiamo france misano
taborra to hell è stato il problema
dimostrò che ritengo comunque di un
livello improponibile a livello di regia
prima di tutto a livello di scenografie
e poi ovviamente a livello di idee credo
si debba dare il merito a martin per
esempio le quella prigione in cui c'era
tyrone per un po quella dove è una
prigione senza una parete che danno un
precipizio quella cosa mira fighissimo
con tra l'altro il pavimento di
leggermente inclinato proprio per farti
stremare a all'infinito quell'ora cosa
fighissima e c'erano molte cose
fighissime ma non mi hanno tenuto in
piedi entrambi i testicoli sono alla
fine caduti tutte e due sotto il mobile
quindi niente ed è molto difficile nel
2014 vivere in un mondo dove non ti
piace game of thrones mi hanno detto
cose perché un conto è su internet dove
sono tutti dietro un computer magari
hanno una faccia da culo te li può
immaginare grassi pelati tutti storti
più pieni di mille problemi incredibili
poi magari non è così ma chissene nella
tua testa e così un altro conto è vivere
24 ore su 24 in casa con una persona che
nonostante tu mettessi 16 mani avanti
nel spiegare le cose non ti fosse
piaciuto di game of thrones ti
rispondeva se non invece che non capisci
niente
sapete che cos'è questo o questi o
questi tutta questa roba papa agli occhi
di un outsider sono pupazzetti di b e
libri di gamestop
per me questo è l'inferno sceso in terra
per uno che non ha visto game of thrones
avere una persona ampo patita di game of
thrones e dirle
a me non è piaciuto non è un
bell'ambiente in cui vivere
però a me non sono stato sincero no sì
ma con ancora capisce un cazzo è che
comunque poi tutte queste cose qui che
mi dice sempre la gente che non sono sei
i cali file più bello del mondo
e voi hai visto the shield no hai visto
del governo lost quelli un po più nuove
tipo break even per un po più vecchio
tipi di file e chi mostra sarebbe il tuo
telefilm preferito perché siete contenti
lo ha ammesso non mi garba game of
thrones che poi perché mai si chiama il
trono di spade perché c'è un trono di
spade che woody è come se breaking bad
si chiamasse vita da camper non perché
c'è un camper che vuol dire non si sa ma
magari sono io che lo capisco un ciufolo
ci vediamo con il prossimo video che
sarà probabilmente ancora peggio il
finale diavolo e metti un bis